dans le cadre des journées européennes
du patrimoine le conseil départemental a
comme chaque année ouvert les portes de
ses équipements culturels au public la
villa du département à proposer une
exposition intitulée mode et traditions
sur des costumes d'époque et de style
au programme visites animations
projections de films sur les costumes et
les danses traditionnelles mais aussi
rencontres et échanges sur les modes et
tradition avec bernadette ladauge figure
artistique locale qui a mis en scène sa
collection privée de costumes d'époque
alors dans cette collection se sont que
des costumes d'époque
c'est à dire que ça va de 1880 à 1980 on
commence par le l'actuel à l'entrée et
puis au fur et à mesure qu'on va passer
on va vraiment et là vous avez les
années soixante dix avec les hippies
ensuite on passe aux années 60 les mini
une map si la petite 3 2 v brigitte
bardot les vichy et au fur et à mesure
on passe dans les années 50 les années
40 et les années 30 des années 20 et les
dernières se sont sales la médiane est
plus ancien qui date de 1881 donc ce
sont des costumes d'époque des costumes
authentiques qui ont été fabriquées et
porté par les gens y vivaient à cette
époque la bibliothèque départementale de
la réunion a proposé une exposition de
vingt-et-une photographies tirées du
livre 60 solution face au changement
climatique des photos présentant des
projets pour lutter contre le
dérèglement climatique
des ateliers ont été proposés aux
enfants autour du développement durable
la bibliothèque a également proposé au
public des rencontres avec plusieurs
auteurs charlotte rabesahala a ainsi pu
présenter son ouvrage et c'est important
pour l'auto de rencontrer le public pour
savoir que le l'écho
comme c'est tout nouveau c'est c'est
important de le savoir
et puis il ya aussi une chose c'est que
il n'y a pas beaucoup de rencontres avec
les auteurs et les journées du
patrimoine sont importants dans ce sens
là et évidemment la bibliothèque
départementale que je remercie ici et
quand même un lieu d'échangés fructueux
pour les auteurs et les autres pour les
auteurs et des zones c'est évident ce
week-end a été une nouvelle fois
l'occasion de démontrer l'attachement de
la collectivité à sauvegarder et à
transmettre le patrimoine